Crawley back with you for Chapter 2.
When a client is hospitalized, the loss of income is only half the battle. The hospital bills themselves can be staggering.
That is where medical expense reimbursement comes in. This coverage steps in to handle hospital, surgical, and medical expenses when a client is confined.
The foundation is Basic Hospital Expense Insurance. This plan provides two main benefits: daily room and board charges and miscellaneous hospital benefits.
These miscellaneous benefits cover the heavy operational costs like the operating room, anesthetics, X-rays, and drugs.
However, you must remind your clients that non-medical incidentals like renting a television or phone service in the room are strictly excluded.
Furthermore, this specific basic plan does not pay the actual doctor's professional fees. To cover the doctors, your client needs Basic Surgical Expense Insurance.
This pays out based on a strict schedule of operations. If a surgery isn't listed on that schedule, the insurance company will consult medical experts to determine a commensurate value.
And take note, cosmetic surgery for beautification is excluded unless it is explicitly necessitated by an accidental injury.
Finally, there is the Physician's Attendance Benefit. This provides a daily allowance for care and treatment by a physician during hospital confinement, calculating the maximum payment by multiplying the daily rate by the number of allowed days.
But basic plans have limits. What happens when a severe, life-threatening illness breaks through those limits and threatens total financial ruin?